arizonans traditionally downplay their
roasting summer temperatures with the
phrase but it's a dry heat
this year the heat is injuring and
killing people
I decided to get a sheet
and drink it with water
and cover myself with it
because it was just too hot I'm not used
to the Arizona heat I've been here for
12 years and
I haven't seen nothing like it
it's hot
the average daily temperature in Phoenix
usually is about 42 degrees Celsius in
the current Heat Wave weather casters
say the average has risen specifically
for the Southwest U.S we're really
concentrated on the heat and so it heat
can develop a little earlier in the
season linger late later later in the
season be a little bit higher and that's
what we're experiencing with this latest
Heat Wave it with the heat wave
projected to last at least another week
the pressure on Arizona residents to
cope or in some cases to survive will
only increase
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera